hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in letter 65 Seneca is explaining to us
the stoic view on causality and its
relation to matter what counts as a
genuine cause what counts is the first
cause and he very helpfully sets the
stoic point of view in relation to two
other metaphysical points of view both
of which were incredibly important in
ancient times and continue to remain so
throughout modern times in modernity and
that would be the Aristotelian notion of
four causes and the Platonic tradition
which brings in the idea or exemplar or
model as a cause as well at least is the
way Aristotle and the Stoics interpreted
Plato and before we go into looking at
that I do want to point out that in this
letter Seneca speaks a little
anachronistically about Aristotle first
introducing three causes and then a
fourth but then Plato introducing a
fifth cause because of course Plato
precedes Aristotle but we could take
this as representing how plate NIST's
are making sense out of the Aristotelian
and proposals
these four causes and again before we go
into his his discussion of those two
great schools he also tells us a little
bit about what the Stoics believe as
he's addressing his interlocutor Luke
Ilyas he says the adherents of our stoic
school say that in the worlds nature
there are two things from which
everything comes into being one of these
is matter which the Stoics conceived of
as essentially inert as having no
movement or energy or shape of its own
and then cause causa which super imposes
upon matter everything that matter is
going to have or exhibit to us he says
matter laser nerve to thing open to all
possibilities because and then he says
that is reason for the Stoics reason is
going to be the cause
shapes matter and turns it into
direction it wants producing it from at
various works and so then it says for
any given thing there has to be
something out of which it is made and
something by which it is made and this
is a somewhat different point of view
than that say the Aristotelian 's
who Seneca will turn to in just a moment
but in a way it's kind of similar to
that of Plato is it not and if you think
about Plato's own account there is some
room for a divine worker at least in
Republic book 10 and in the Timaeus now
putting all that aside the next thing
that Seneca does in this letter is go
through the traditionally understood
Aristotelian for causes and as I pointed
out he actually says that there's three
causes that Aristotle recognizes the
word cause is used in three ways the
first cause is the material itself the
matter the materia in Latin and a little
bit later when he's talking about these
five causes he will call that edx quo
that out of which so the matter of
course for this book
is paper which is really would put
together in a different way the matter
for this tie is cloth which is really
threads of things woven together in a
certain way made from wool or in this
case I imagine probably silk or
something like that I don't see a tag
for it right away and we could go on and
on and on the matter for this chalkboard
is a kind of slate perhaps I really know
what goes into this this chalkboard as
such but you have matter that which has
been shaped that which has been formed
that which has been acted upon that
which the thing is out of then you have
and Seneca is going to use several
different terms here the agent or maker
the actually the first term that he use
is not artifacts but OPA facts right
though the maker the one who does the
work artifacts the one who actually
fashioned something and this is it aqua
in the the summary that he's going to
give here that by which the thing comes
to be so again we'll take the tie in the
book and we'll use his other example of
the statue in a moment there was an
entire production process that made this
book what it was and presumably the same
thing with his tie as well which is a
hundred percent so yes I see and so we
could go on and say well the silk didn't
make itself into this this form there
had to be some sort of maker or
production process that did them then we
have the form or the the shape if you
like the structure of it and here he
calls that it in quo that in which the
thing is and so here we have to extend
our thinking a little bit how is it that
how is it in the form right well this is
in the shape of the form right it has
been wrought in a certain way by the
maker who took the material and produced
that effect
then we can go on and talk about a
fourth cause as Aristotle does in fact
this is what Aristotle takes to be one
of his main contributions to metaphysics
the purpose or end or good or goal
however you want to define it it probe
their quote that on account of which the
thing has been done and a little bit
later Seneca will say that there could
be all sorts of different causes right
it could be money if you craft something
to sell or reputation if you want to
make a name for yourself or reverence
if you fashion it the thing is a gift
for a temple right this is a reason why
something is the way it is and when it
comes to things that are not mad you
know
artifacts right but rather things like
us organisms we might talk about the
final clause in a somewhat different way
as the purpose that we're supposed to
attain or achieve and this is what
Aristotle recognized and so we can look
at the example of the bronze statue that
Aristotle himself used and which Seneca
invokes here right bronze is the first
cause of the statue you don't have a
statue if you don't have something that
it's made out of then the second cause
is the craftsperson the agent the person
who actually forms the statue the third
is the form and he says quite
interestingly the statue would not be
called a spear bearer or a youth tying a
headband these were popular modes you
could say of statues back then certain
ways of doing it just like we might say
you know thick tie skinny tie power tie
we've got all these descriptors right
that is a form and then we have the
reason why it has produced the purpose
of making it if that had not been there
it would not have been made and then
here's what is motivating the
craftsperson it could be just be the art
itself right now Seneca goes on and says
Plato adds a fifth cause to this so
Aristotle's account according to Seneca
at this
is not yet complete for explaining
causality what is the fifth cause that
Plato adds well it's the model or
another way of translating this the
pattern or the idea the exempt l'm in in
Latin example would would work in the
sense of a paradigm right the thing that
it's modeled after it odd quo the thing
that you're looking to and trying to
make that that material thing that
you're creating resemble and Plato views
these forms as something immaterial so
the way that sonica reads this he says
this is what the craftsman had in view
when he made that which he intended to
make it doesn't matter whether he has an
external model to cast his eyes upon or
an internal one that he himself has
conceived and set up within at this
point it sounds a little bit different
than what Plato has in mind as a form or
idea but then Seneca goes on to say
something quite interesting he tells us
that God has these models of all things
within himself or whatever God is and
encompasses in his mind the numbers and
measures of everything that is to be
achieved
he's full of those shapes that Plato
calls ideas deathless changeless
tireless so for Seneca within God's mind
these eternal ideas exist already
and the craftsperson or Plato when Plato
is trying to describe what goes on is
talking about what's in the mind of God
now this is an interesting account and
in a way you could put together Plato
and Aristotle two accounts together and
you would encompass a lot of what we
call causality Seneca does not remain
content with this however and says that
there's a problem here either they have
too few causes or they have too many
causes and why would there be too few he
says from the stoic point of view
we're not taking every single thing into
account that goes into making a thing
what it is because we've left out two
factors we in addition to all these
other causes we would also need to think
about time and about motion and then he
dismisses that because his intent is not
actually to introduce a whole bunch of
other causes he wants to reduce it all
to one cause and that cause is what he
calls creative reason that's a good way
to translate it gratia Fakih ends the
the reason rotc oh that makes that
shapes that that forms Fakih ends right
from thought journey and that he says is
God Deus this is essentially what in
Greek they would call the logo spermatic
O's and he goes on to say that God has
all of these things all of these aspects
which put these other causes into a kind
of context so he says God here we go all
the things you've mentioned are not
multiple individual causes but dependent
on one the one that makes that is God so
you say that form is a cause form is
according to Seneca what the craftsman
imposes on his work it's part of the
cause but it's not the cause itself so
Aristotle is wrong and calling it a
cause the model Plato's idea is
necessary to the craftsman but it's
necessary as an instrument so it's not a
cause somebody might say the aim of the
craftsman is a cause even supposing it
is a cause Seneca will say it's not the
efficient cause but a what he calls
supervenient and that's just translating
the latin soup interventions cause right
something added on top of it it adds a
little explanatory power but it's not
why the thing is the way it is for
Seneca why
is the thing it why it is the way that
it is is because God formed it that way
that is the primary cause so he goes on
and he says these causes are in Newman
enumerable what we're looking for is the
generic cause so God or creative reason
winds up being the explanatory principle
for everything and all of these other
ways of understanding causality from
Senecas point of view which he is taking
to be the orthodox stoic point of view
are merely accessory merely modes of
what is going on here
in and as a result of the mind of God
you